let's say you run an orange stand and
this right here is you could do this
either as the demand curve for your
orange tan or your marginal benefit
curve or really call it the willingness
to pay that the first hundred pounds of
oranges or that very hundredths pound
that hundredths pounds someone would be
willing to pay $3 per pound but then the
hundreds in first pound it would be a
little bit less than that so that's the
willingness to pay or the marginal
benefit of that incremental pound but
let's say you decide to site set the
price at $2 and you are able to sell 300
300 oranges per in that week what I want
to think about is what is the total
consumer consumer surplus that your
consumers got and the way to think about
consumer surplus is how much benefit did
they get above and beyond what they paid
so for example the person who bought
let's just think about the exact the
hundredth pound the hundredth pound they
paid $2 sorry yeah they paid $2 but
their benefit looks like it was like I
don't know 3 dollars and 30 cents so 3
dollars and 30 cents but they only paid
$2 so their benefit on that 1 pound
there marked their benefit or their I
should say their consumer surplus is
going to be 330 minus the 230 so that
person who bought that hundredth pound
that not all the hundred pounds just
that hundredth pound
got a consumer surplus of 330 minus 2
dollars which is a $1 and 30 consumer
surplus consumer surplus so if you
wanted to figure out the entire consumer
surplus well you would just have to do
it for all of the pounds so that was the
hundredth pound you would find you would
find so that essentially that was the
you could view this as the area of this
little thing right over here and let me
zoom in just to make sure you understand
what's going on that thing that I just
drew if we zoom in will look something
like this it was 1 pound wide it was 1
pound wide 1 pound 1 pound wide and it
was this right over here this right over
here was $2 and then we had D and then
we had our marginal benefit curve our
demand curve sloping down like that
sloping down like that
and this point right over here was three
dollars and thirty and so to figure out
the consumer surplus for that pound we
said okay for that pound they were
willing to pay three dollars thirty the
benefit to them was three dollars and
thirty but they only had to pay two
dollars so the height of this the height
of this right over here was one dollar
thirty and so the consumer surplus is
one dollar thirty per pound times one
pound times one pound and so that's what
that's where we got the one dollar
thirty consumer surplus now we could do
that for every one of the pounds so we
could do that for the hundredth and
first pound
let me did a different colored one
hundredth and first pound we would do it
like that then the one hundred then
second pound we would do it like that
one hundredths and third pound like that
we do it for the 99th pound like that
and so you could imagine if we want to
find the total consumer surplus what are
we doing well we're essentially just
finding the area between our demand
curve and this line where the price is
equal to two so we're just going to sum
up this area and if you're familiar with
calculus you might know that it you can
actually make these things arbitrarily
small you could take smaller and smaller
you could you don't have to take a one
pile a one-pound wide rectangle you
could take a half a pound wide rectangle
or a quarter pound wide rectangle then
you'll just have more rectangles it
doesn't matter so much if you have a
linear demand curve but if you had a
nonlinear demand curve then it would
matter you'd want to get smaller and
smaller and smaller or thinner and
thinner and thinner rectangles so you
could get better and better
approximations for the consumer surplus
but needless to say what you're really
doing especially if you find if you get
unbelievably thin rectangles and you
have an unbelievably high number of them
you're really just estimating the area
under the demand curve and above and
above the price equals two dollars and
so if you want to know this consumer
surplus and I really want you to
understand why this was I mean just
think about it for each pound it was
just how much more value that pound
whoever bought that pound how much more
value do they get relative to what they
paid and we're just summing that up
across all of the pounds so to really
figure out the total consumer surplus we
just have to find the area this area of
this blue area and that's just finding
the area of a triangle
so this right over here you have a base
of 300 this length right over here is
300 300 pounds and then our height our
height over here and we can we can just
do use this as the area of a triangle
because this is a this is a simple
linear demand curve we would actually
have to use a little bit of calculus if
this was a nonlinear curve but the
height here is 2
the height here is 2 so our area the
area between the demand curve and our
price equals 2 is equal to 1/2 times
base times height 1/2 times the base
which is 300 pounds times 300 pounds
times the height which is 2 dollars
which is $2.00 per pound times $2 all
right this way times $2 $2 per pound the
pounds cancel out 1/2 times 2 is 1 times
300 is 300 so we get 300 300 and all
we're left with is dollars so the total
consumer surplus in this case is $300
and it really is just the area between
the demand curve and this price equals 2
line right over there